Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and
that number is two one nine two.
David P..
This is kind of a funny voicemail.
I've been saying in in a serious way.
In a genuine way.
I'm not sure if Matt Gates gets indicted.
The investigation is heating back up and we're
looking at whether he was involved in child
sex trafficking and many other crimes.
I don't know that he gets indicted.
That's not what this caller thinks.
Take a listen to this.
Speaker 4: I may I agree with virtually everything
you're saying every day.
Beautiful.
But one of the funniest things you ever said
was that about seven fifty five p.m. Central
Time on Wednesday.
Saying that we don't know whether Matt Gates
is going to be indicted or not.
Right.
I don't know if you're just hedging or what,
but.
He's going down and there's no ifs, ands or
buts.
He's done it's just a matter of when.
Thanks.
Keep up the good work.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I was not hedging.
If this is the United States where we have
two justice systems.
And the reality is that even being an unhinged
and delusional member of Congress, you're
still a member of Congress and there's a certain
amount of privilege that that confers.
And in all of those cases, I hesitate to assume
that there are going to be legal consequences.
So, no, I was not hedging.
We'll see if you are right.
We'll see if you're right.
We will see if he gets indicted.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
Elon Musk tweeted last night that Tesla is
not going to continue accepting Bitcoin for
Tesla vehicles and it tanked the price of
Bitcoin.
And we are going to talk about the implications
long term, medium term and short term.
We are also finding, as if you didn't know
from what's been going on for the last year,
there is a trust problem when it comes to
public health officials in the United States.
It's disproportionately a problem from the
American right, as you probably would guess.
And we will also talk about the sort of red
line or line in the sand that Republicans
are drawing for Joe Biden.
And they did it in this Oval Office meeting
that took place yesterday.
So much to discuss all of those stories and
more when producer Pat joins me on today's
bonus show, Get Instant Access by becoming
a member at Join Pakman dot com.
Unidentified: We'll see you then.